[Music]
Jona I'll be I've known you for a bunch
of years and I've always thought of you
was a manly man a man who's in touch
with his manliness and who's very manly
yeah that's true that's how I got good
night everybody but I actually know I I
read an interview that you that you feel
that you have a strong female side yes
there was one of those little things I
said in an interview of like actually I
have a really strong feminine side john
c reilly is woman you know like the
headline came as a result of that one
little comment but yeah i think i think
in general the world is kind of shifting
gender identity is shifting and people
are recognizing the fact that we're not
all male or all female that there's
degrees within us and i'm like a kind of
a typical gemini where you know split
personality and i do have a very
sensitive side and and even though I
look like an Irish cro-magnon Paul these
are things like you know being
understanding and being sensitive to
other people's feelings and you know
fancy frocks and Judy Garland and Barbra
Streisand that kind of thing everything
into them you're into all that yeah yeah
okay do you have a strong female side
yeah I mean I was pretty I was also like
my parents divorced early so I was
raised by women and I think I relate to
women there you go probably almost more
so than I do men yeah great no joke I
and I definitely had the camp Broadway
gene so yeah that's pretty womanly yeah
I was I was raised in musical so maybe
that's where it comes from
I'm completely asexual gender neutral
maybe one day you find yeah feel free to
ask my crying wife
you